you're learning new details this morning
about the Texas Church gunman's very
troubled past
devon patrick kelly was the subject of a
sex assault complaint back in 2013 the
Comal County Texas sheriff said
yesterday the investigation stalled when
Kelly moved to Colorado survivors of
Sunday's massacre are providing heroin
the details about how the gunman
methodically targeted his victims
mark Strassmann is outside the First
Baptist Church in Sutherland Springs
with what investigators are discovering
now mark good morning good morning that
sex assault case is part of an emerging
pattern involved in the dead gunmen for
years his brooding disposition and short
fuse scared people he was troubled long
before he massacred people in this
church it sounds like he didn't want to
take his finger off the trigger he was
like constant it wouldn't let off
Lorenzo Flores was at the gas station
across the street when Devon Kelly began
firing into this wood frame Church
how many shots
[Music]
rounds round as much as he could put in
there I guess he was non-stop for the
roughly 50 worshipers inside it was the
beginning of about four minutes of
terror as the gunmen moved pew - pew
everybody get down they're shooting at
us
Rose n Solis and her husband were both
wounded but played dead on the floor
they said the gunman yelled everybody
dies and showed no mercy
not even to crying babies it was so
scary and that man was shooting I mean
he was shooting hard on Tuesday the
killers dark pass came into sharper
focus a sex assault investigation in
2013 and escaped from a mental health
facility and in 2012 El Paso Police
report that described him as a danger to
himself and others he had been sneaking
firearms into Holloman Air Force Base
where he was stationed and made death
threats to his commanding officers five
months later he was convicted of beating
his then wife and stepchild 136 Texas
Rangers are involved in the crime scene
investigation at First Baptist Church
which police hope to wrap up tonight
getting evidence out of the killer's
cell phone however may take considerably
longer they cannot unlock it FBI Special
Agent in Charge Kris coves I don't know
how long that's going to be to be quite
honest with you it could be tomorrow it
could be a week could be a month we just
don't know yet
about half the people inside that church
on Sunday were killed five days earlier
the government actually attended the
church's Fall Festival but nothing about
that visit raised alarms Norah it's
stunning to hear that mark thank you